[Music]
thank you
one of the features of the Nazi regime
that existed historically in our
timeline and in the alternate history of
World War II and beyond that is
represented in Philip K Dick's novel The
Man in the High Castle is that Nazis on
one level get along and on another level
don't there's conflict that happen
within the Nazi regime all sorts of
overlapping areas of responsibility
competition between different portions
and parts of the regime occasionally
even purges that take place and so
there's this tendency and this is a word
that dick uses several times
by several different characters thinking
this International
conflict and what is what does this mean
this means conflict that is destructive
to both sides
and we see several different characters
making an observation about it this now
there is one upside to at least certain
people within the regime the leader
whoever happens to be in charge in this
case the chancellor the the you know
fewer the the person who governs from
the top by keeping other people within
their hierarchy at odds with each other
they can assure their position and this
is indeed what Hitler himself did in the
Nazi regime now in this timeline Hitler
uh succumbed to you know effects of
syphilis and was replaced by Borman his
secretary who who actually in real life
did exercise quite a bit of Power by
controlling who had access to Hitler as
Hitler was particularly going into
mental decline as the war got worse and
worse and in this timeline Borman has
been in charge urge for quite a while
but there's still a lot of recognizable
Nazi figures doing things
involved in a power struggle that's
going to come when Borman himself dies
and before we get into that power
struggle which is setting the scope of
the entire novel and perhaps even
leading to World War III
we should see how this actually plays
out at a lower level so we have these
very interesting little vignettes with
for example two different Nazi officials
within the Pacific States of America
where which is run by the Japanese so we
in chapter eight at eight o'clock in the
morning fry hair Hugo rice the reichs
council in San Francisco stepped from
his Mercedes-Benz 2220e and walked
briskly up the steps of the consulate
behind him came two young male employees
of the foreign office so this is his
domain right and there is uh his his
secretary here ferdhoff who says there's
a coded radiogram coming in now from
Berlin preface one and uh so then 10
minutes ago here kreutzville mayor
called he said he would like you to
return his call and he's getting himself
some some morning breakfast
and then we have this interesting
reflection the caller kreutz from Mira
was the chief of the sickerdin's height
in the PSA area the SD that's referenced
over and over again the security uh
police essentially his headquarters were
located under a cover name at the Air
Terminal relations between rice and
kreuzfomero were rather strained their
jurisdictions overlapped in countless
matters a deliberate policy no doubt of
the higher-ups in Berlin rice held an
honorary Commission in the SS the rank
of major and this made him technically
kreuzval matter is subordinate
the commission had been bestowed several
years ago and at that time rice had
discerned the purpose but he could do
nothing about it nonetheless he chafed
still and so this is you know sort of
institutional uh being at odds as we see
um there's an interesting discussion as
well later on in chapter 12 when Baines
who is actually Rudolph Wagner is
summarizing what's going on
um talking about who's got control over
what right and uh he talks about uh
who's got the the power in things for
example the Vermont the militaries of
sole possession in the Reich of the
hydrogen bomb where the black shirts
have used it they've done so only under
Army supervision the Chancery under
Borman never allowed any nuclear
Armament to go to the police right and
they're talking about operation
dandelion which we're going to explore
in Greater detail later
then he he you know he talks about the
local SD not really knowing anything
Christ Romero being essentially a
stuffed shirt an old-time party hack an
ALT party genoza an imbecile no one in
Berlin would think of telling him
anything
um and then he goes on as well and talks
about his own organization the op they
are which we're going to get to later
and he says your your establishment the
op Fair it would be futile to attempt to
reach heydrich through you and uh Wagner
replies the black shirts utterly revile
us they've been trying for 20 years to
get parte approval for liquidating Us in
Toto so we've got these different
factions kind of vying against each
other at odds with each other right and
we also see Wagner engaging in some very
interesting Reflections after he has
been picked up and manages not to die
right so
we find out that you know he thought
perhaps he might be taken uh you know to
die because he's of the op there the the
uh intelligence Services
counterintelligence actually and
um a little bit later after he asked the
SS men
um how are things any recent
developments in the political situation
I've been away for several weeks before
borman's death in fact the man to his
right answer there's naturally plenty of
hysterical mob support for the little
doctor that's gerbils it was the mob
that swept him into office however it's
unlikely that when more sober elements
Prevail they'll want to support a
and demagogue who depends on
inflaming the mass with his lies and
spellbinding and then wegner's thinking
to himself it goes on
the internecine hate perhaps the seeds
are there in that they will eat each
other uh eat one another at last and
leave the rest of us here and there in
the world still alive still enough of us
wants more to build and hope and make a
few simple plans and that's sort of the
best case scenario that these Nazis will
go at Cross purposes wipe each other out
and more rational more Humane people
will be able to rebuild human
civilization
now moving on from that in this power
struggle what's actually happening we
get our first hint of it and our first
interesting assessment on the part of
Julianne Frank and she um is reading and
she thinks about the Nazis and what's
going on with them
and she uh is reflecting she says maybe
guring will be the new fearer when that
Borman dies he seems kind of different
from the others the only way that Borman
got it in the first place was to weasel
in when Hitler was falling apart and
those actually near only those near
Hitler realized how fast he was going
old gutering was off in his Mountain
Palace guring should have been fewer
after Hitler because it was his
luftwaffe that knocked out those English
radar stations then finished off the RAF
Hitler would have had them bomb London
like they did Rotterdam but possibly
goobles so we have a second person we'll
get it she decided that's what everyone
said right so the majority are talking
about that as long as that awful
heydrich doesn't and we're going to see
heydrich is going to play an important
role he'll kill us all he's really bats
the one I like she thought is that
balder Von Shirak he's the only one who
looks normal anyhow but he hasn't got a
chance and so this is sort of like you
know not particularly well informed
persons take on these power figures and
then we see that tagomi has been uh
summoned as many others to this very
important meeting at the embassy
and so we're going to get an assessment
here
sirs the foreign office person said in
loud commanding voice as you know the
reich's counselor is now confirmed as
dead official statement from Berlin this
meeting which will not last long you
will soon be able to go back to your
offices is for purposes of informing you
of our evaluation of several contending
factions in German political life who
can now be expected to step forth and
engage in No Holds Barred disputation
the internecine conflict for spot
evacuated by hair Borman briefly the
notables so who do we have first
goodread
and it says the fat one so-called due to
body originally courageous air ace and
first world war founded gestapo and held
post-impression government of vast power
one of the most ruthless early Nazis yet
later sybaritic excesses gave rise to
misguiding picture of amiable wine
tippling disposition which our
government urges you to reject this man
although said to be unhealthy perhaps
even morbidly so in terms of appetites
resembles more of the self-gratifying
ancient Roman Caesars whose power grew
rather than abated as age progressed
lurid picture of this person in toga
with pet lions owning a men's Castle
filled with trophies and art objects is
no doubt accurate he goes on our
evaluation this man craves enormous
power and is capable of obtaining it
most self-indulgent of all Nazis and is
in sharp contrast to late uh Himmler who
lived in personal want at low salary
hair goodering representative of spoils
mentality using power as means of
acquiring personal wealth primitive
mentality even vulgar but quite
intelligent man possibly most
intelligent of all Nazi Chiefs object of
his drives
self-glorification and ancient emperor
fashion so we've got the first of the
possible successors
next hair gerbils suffered polio and
youth originally Catholic brilliant
orator writer flexible and fanatic mind
witty Urbane Cosmopolitan much active
with ladies elegant educated highly
capable does much work almost frenzied
managerial Drive much respected
personages personage can be Charming but
is said to have rabid streak unmatched
by other Nazis ideological orientation
suggesting medieval jesuitic Viewpoint
exacerbated by post-romantic German
nihilism considered Soul authentic
intellectual of the parte had Ambitions
to be playwright few friends not like by
subordinates but nevertheless highly
polished product of many best elements
in European culture not
self-gratification as underlying
ambition but power for its use purely
organizational attitude and classic
Prussian States sense so now we've got
two
here we get the third
heydrich
much younger individual than above who
helped original revolution in 1932
career man with Elite SS subordinate of
of Himmler may have played role in
himmler's not fully yet explained death
in 1948. officially eliminated other
contestants within police apparatus such
as Eichmann Schellenberg and others
feared by many parte people responsible
for controlling their mocked elements
after close of hostilities in famous
clash between police and army which led
to reorganization of governmental
apparatus out of this the nsdap emerging
Victor supported Berman throughout
product of Elite Training and yet
anterior to so-called SS Castle system
said to be devoid of affective mentality
in traditional sense enigmatic in terms
of Drive possibly may be said to have
view of society which holds humans
struggle to be series of games peculiar
quasi-scientific Detachment found also
in certain technological circles not
party to ideological disputes summation
can be called most modern in mentality
post-enlightenment type dispensing with
so-called necessary Illusions such as
belief in God meaning of this so-called
realistic mentality cannot be fathomed
by social scientists in Tokyo so this
man must be considered a question mark
however notice of resemblance to
deterior deterioration of affectivity
and pathological schizophrenia should be
made
then we have the fourth Contender we've
already seen Juliana talking about him
balder Von Shirak former head of Hitler
Youth considered idealist personally
attractive but considered not highly
experienced or competent sincere
believer in goals aparthe took
responsibility for draining
Mediterranean and reclaiming of huge
areas of Farmland also mitigated vicious
policies of racial extermination and
Slavic lands in early 50s pled case
directly to German people for remnants
of Slavic peoples to exist on
reservation-like closed regions in
Heartland area called for end of certain
forms of Mercy killings and medical
experimentation but failed here so with
Von Shirak we have somebody who's a bit
more Humane than these other Nazi
leaders and then we get cess inquart
former Austrian Nazi now in charge of
right Colonial areas responsible for
colonial policies possibly most hated
man in right territory said to have
instigated most if not all repressive
measures dealing with conquered peoples
worked for roe with Rosenberg for
ideological victories of most alarming
grandiose type such as attempt to
sterilize entire Russian population no
facts for certain on this but considered
to be one of several responsible for a
decision to make Holocaust of African
continent thus creating genocide
conditions for negro population
possibly closest in temperament to
original Fury and the meeting goes on
and tagomi leaves because he doesn't
want to hear any more of this it's
really getting to him there is
interestingly a summary that's given a
not a Japanese assessment of the
probabilities of what would go on and
this is where the non-ferrous oars man
is going to give a prognosis he says we
must presume the worst rather than the
best choice will be made the sober and
responsible elements will be defeated in
the present Clash tagumi says well who's
that and so then the the guy says
heydrich say
sinquartering in the Imperial
government's position and who would be
the best
possibly Financial Iraq and gerbils
so this is you know quite interesting
the Japanese are preparing for any one
of these to get power but it's probably
going to be one of the bad ones right so
either guring or heydrich or in court
and they initially think that googles
would be not one of the bad choices but
he would actually be one of the worst
and gibbles will in fact take power
there is also a very interesting
speculation in the office of rice the
the council
so he asks his subordinate do you want
to make a bet on who's actually going to
come out and his subordinate says not on
the on the deliberations and rice says
it's going to be the hangman namely
heydrich and faridhof says heydrich has
gone as far as he can those people never
pass over to direct part take control
because everyone is scared of them the
parte bigwigs would have a fit even at
the idea you'd get a Coalition in 25
minutes as soon as the first SS Car took
off from Prince Albert strassa they'll
have all those economic Big Shots like
Krupp and Tyson and so you know it goes
on from there and as it turns out who is
going to take charge it will be gribbles
growing is going to go along with it and
heydrich seemingly goes along with it at
least in the scene that we're going to
look at next right but heydrich is is
the Rival power in the succession so now
we come back to Rudolph Wegner and this
is a very important point right he
identifies himself in this meeting with
the Japanese is general and which tagomi
is mediating right
and
um here's an all from an old monarchist
family as they find out so he's got some
sort of attachment to that and he
identifies himself as part of Naval
Counter Intelligence the op there so
this is a faction that is actually
opposed to all these other factions and
as we can see Wagner himself is worried
about the evil not only that the Nazi
regime has done but the greater evil
that it's degenerating into and we have
this very interesting call that takes
place in chapter
11. so uh rice and
um Christopher Mara are both in the
office at the time Googles calls up rice
and says
General Hedrick has just asked me to
call you there's an agent of the opvair
there in San Francisco his name is
Rudolph Wegner you are to cooperate
fully with the police regarding him
there isn't time to give you details
simply put your office at your disposal
and so you know what's going to happen
is the council is going to write up an
authorization to return Wagner to
Germany forcibly there will be an attack
which is going to actually be foisted by
tagomi as we'll we'll find out later
who's using a old pistol to do that
Wagner himself is going to wind up uh
getting picked up on his way back to
Germany right and we have this very
interesting vignette where he's at the
the airport black shirts that's the SS
who belong to the the uh heydricks thing
are are there to pick him up and they
say aren't you Captain Rudolph Wegner
from the op there and he says no no I'm
Conrad goltz representing A.G chemical
on medical supplies the black shirts
come up to him they fall in with them
they say you're Wagner we have a car
we're instructed to meet your rocket
ship contact you and take you
immediately to General Hedrick who is
with sep Dietrich at the okw of the
leipestandarta division in particular we
are not to permit you to be approached
by Vermont army or parte party people
then I will not be shot Wagner said to
himself heydrich is alive and in a safe
location and trying to strengthen his
position against the Google's government
maybe the Google's government will fall
after all he thought as he was ushered
into the Daimler staff sedan
um what does it matter though he says
even if gibbles is exposed or deposed
and operation dandelion is canceled they
will still exist the black shirts the
parte the schemes if not in the orient
than somewhere else on Mars and Venus
right so he's he's considering all these
things that we've talked about in his
Reflections and what do we see here the
Nazi regime is always at odds with
itself which opens up possibilities
where things are sort of over determined
not just of conflict but of action that
can escape the official Nazi ideology
but it all depends as well on who is
going to to be in power and I'll close
by saying that we've mentioned operation
dandelion we're going to talk about that
elsewhere it this is going to require
the Japanese government to work with the
people that they consider the most
ruthless and Evil Within the Nazi regime
namely those of heydrich and his SD and
SS people in order to prevent a global
catastrophe for Humanity by these quite
crazy Nazis so there you have it power
struggles that are going on not just at
the very top but also in the lower
levels of the Nazi State apparatus